looking at what you know about the
current approach that the super rich
have when it comes to saving themselves
from the apocalypse that's coming what
are the most fragile elements of their
preparation security definitely any of
them that are land-based we can go take
them over there's more of us even if a
thousand of us get shot on our way in
the ones that are totally locked away
they're agriculture systems are totally
self-contained a lot of them have like
their topsoilers and these little rubber
tubes have you ever seen somebody doing
vertical farming at home or whatever you
get a bad batch and you just take it out
and go get some topsoil and build
another one you can't do that when
you're locked away or what do you do you
go out with a crew with a couple of guys
with a machine to run and find some more
sterile topsoil but of course you got
the nuclear fallout and the zombies and
the Killer Bees the thing that failed
with biosphere will fail with a lot of
these because they think everything's
going to regenerate